OUR AGE POINETHER OR NOT
RU ARE HAVING AN PROBLEMHE
THEIR OFFENSIVE ISTING.
T MOVE IN MOMENT THAN E IN THE
S A MASSIVE COLUMNN ARMORED VEHL
ARE GOING PAST URIW.
TO THEM A
RICA, AS WET
WHAT YOU'ROW, I
MAIN BATTLE TANK OF TH
RUSSIANS.
AT-72 BA
WE'RE SEEING A CUM TANKS W ARTA
ADING TOWAS THE FRONT LINE
NEAR KRK
AS WE SPEAHEREE
THE INVASION THAF UKRAINIA
TERRITORY GOING ON,
OBVIOUSLY, MOVING FORWARD ASSSIO
THAT WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT THE
THE DAY.
MORE O HEA
MOVING TOWARDS THELET EANS THAT
TH, BUT IT'S CERTALY
THAT WE'RE DEFINITELY SEEING A
LOT MORE STUFF GOINGRAINIAY.
ALAIN, AS A G MULT RT LAUNS
COMING PAST, ROCTS MON OCCURRENE
E OF THE OTHER INT
THINGS IS TH A LOT OTHES
TROOPS ARE
SMALL AG
AVING TROUBLE WITH
TH A LOT OF THESE KINDF
OF VEHICLES PARKED AROUND HERE
READY  G TIME.ASOU SEEE RUSSIAN.
IF WE GOK E  THEREN E TH
WHAT YOU'R I    C
GOIN TOWKRAINIANORY.
THST CHECK POINT
BEFORE YOUETO THAT
GIF KHAR
T TURNT THE ST CHECKOILE MIL
YON UKINITORY.
AGAIN, WHETHER O
WHETHER OR NOT THIS CAMPAIGN I
RYIFO SAY  OUR VGEATT THE  DEFIR
SOMETHING, FRERIAT THESEEING T
URNTIRE
WE'RETHE TOWN OS E
U.S. SAYS ISMAELD,EA E MOGHN WA
YOER S NOWN THAT GENERAL
BORDER TOWARD UKRAIN E THERE'
THATD Y NOW THAT NIGHTFALL IN CE
OF A FEW DAYS?
>> Reporter: IS STING TO
E.
IT REALLY IS HAS
SET THAT WE'VE SEEA
OF THA.
I DON'T KN W
DAY,OMETHING THE
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
D SAER KIND GE
THAT WE'VEHERE
MU
THAT OVER THE PAST COUPL YSO US
ON TOWARHA.
Y THE VEHICLES, A LOTOFEH
E
S.
MO
RIGHT NOE.BARTH, A LOTR S SOR
D INTTLE TANKS IS NOTHAT WVELOT.
TELL WHETHER OR NOT THAT MEANS